Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and welcome to the RIFE healing webinar. I want to give you some criteria that I use when I look at adding tools to a patient's protocol, tools that may help them heal, change their life, deal with critical issues that they're facing.
Let me share my screen here and talk about this.
When I look at a RIFE machine, there's four criteria that I look at to really make a difference in a person's life.
It has to have it a power to penetrate. It has to use light frequencies. It has to be programmable and it has to be easy to use. Let me explain these a little bit.
A RIFE machine is using frequencies to affect a person's body. That's the whole idea. And all RIFE's work is using light frequencies.
So the machine has to be using light frequencies and programmable to the frequencies that we want to use.
So if we're trying to kill Lyme disease in a person's body, we can program it to known frequencies for burgodorphine and all the other co-infections that go along with Lyme disease.
If we're trying to help the body work on killing cancer cells, we can program it to that specific cancer frequency. And there's many for each cancer.
So you have to be able to program it specifically to the patient's needs.
That's a key component. People will say I used a RIFE machine. It really didn't work.
Well, they may have used a RIFE machine and it didn't work because of these four criteria not being met.
It has to be a tool that can penetrate the person's body so that the frequencies can actually affect the cells that we want it to set.
It has to be using light frequency because light is a different frequency than sound and electrical frequency.
It's a photon on a wavelength and that makes a big difference in how it's affecting the cells.
And then if you're not running the right frequencies for what you're trying to affect in the body, if I have Lyme disease and I'm running viral frequencies that have nothing to do with any co-infections of Lyme, what's not going to do anything?
So we need to be running the right frequencies for the specific cancer. We need to be running the right frequencies for the specific disease.
That's the only way it's going to effectively make positive changes in a person's body.
And then it has to have some ease of use for the patient to use it.
I know people that have purchased different machinery in the past and it was difficult and clumsy to use.
They didn't see results with it. So they gave up on it, which may or may not have been a fear to that piece of equipment.
But I want a piece of equipment that my patients are going to use.
We've seen too many just miraculous results with right machine. So I'm pretty biased.
I've been using the right machine since the late 90s. So a long time.
We have program right machines for patients since that time and run specific frequency sets for patients since that time.
So we have a lot of experience in running right for patients. We've seen literal miracles.
Patients that had two months to live with a pancreatic cancer diagnosis stage four and live for another three and a half years.
Or patients that had, you know, a cancer that they were told to go home and call hospice and they lived in other five years.
We've seen that over and over again.
But even in saying that we want to be careful to not give the impression that a right with sheet isn't panacea of all disease.
It's not a magic one.
You have to have a healthy enough immune system. You, in my opinion, you should do other things that help stimulate your immune response to help deal with the problem at hand.
And the right machine is not just for cancer and it's not just for line.
It's for literally anything. So any issue that you're dealing with frequencies can change things simply because from a quantum physics perspective.
Everything is frequency every piece of matter is simply energy that's vibrating a specific frequency and if you hit it and its own frequency, you can do pretty magical things with it.
This is the machine that we use. It's called the true right F122 is the latest model currently.
The machine is quite simple and it's quite small. It's connected to a computer not seen here. And that's how we put the program. So I write the program for the patient on the computer.
And then it also comes with almost 2500 other programs pre program things from things like foot fungus to viral programs to anything your heart can imagine pretty much.
I think it is specific as possible to that patient. So if a patient buys a right machine from us, we find out what is this patient really dealing with.
If they're not dealing with anything specific that they don't need a specific program, but most people are.
So they might have a history of live disease. They might have a history of Epstein bar. They may have a history and are currently dealing with cancer.
Then we want to get as specific as possible for that patient is that's how you're going to see results. And you need to use this on a regular basis.
That's another mistake people use with the right machine. They think that they're going to run it once or twice or a dozen times and their problems going to magically go away.
This is a frequencies and you have to be affecting those cells on a very regular basis.
Our cancer patients, we write programs that they're running every single night while they sleep.
If they're fairly, you know, not ambulatory doing very poorly like a lot of our patients are they may be running day programs that I write for them as well.
But at least they're running the programs every night while they sleep so they're getting seven eight nine hours of frequency sets that are hitting those cancer cells stimulated in a mute response so that your immune system can effectively see them as the enemy and start to kill them.
That's what our goal is with the right. You can't just do it once or twice. You got to stay very regular with it.
The other picture you see is the bulb that we use. This is the crystal hammer bomb that we use with our patients to use overnight sets.
So they're running this. The bulb is the treatment parameter. It's not attached to you. It's sitting next to you in bed.
We tell people to snuggle with the bulb. Keep it up close to your body. Get used to, you know, it be in your new teddy bear at night.
Those frequencies go out from the bulb. They will penetrate your body and they go out effectively about 07 to 8 feet.
But really the closer it is to you, the more beneficial effect it's going to have on you.
The benefit of this bulb is you could drop it on the floor. You won't break it. Nothing's attached to you. You get up to go to the bathroom. You leave the bulb in bed. You come back. You snuggle with the bulb.
I personally use the right every night for my cancer diagnosis. And I'm out at the time of this webinar just over five years. So praise God.
We give him all the glory and all things. But this is the right machine that we use. This is the package that we sent home with people comes with the computer comes with the program that I personally write for my patients.
Anybody that purchases a knife from us. And it comes with a foot bath apparatus that's not even seen in this picture. We want everybody to have every tool that they possibly can.
Now, I believe in using tools wisely. If a person's main issue is mercury toxicity, well, then they need to do chelation therapy and detox therapy along with rife.
And rife might not be the first tool that I would pick, but it certainly could help with liver detox pathways. And using the foot bath apparatus could help with detox through the water as well.
But using tools appropriately, a person can see great results. That's why we have our courses on all sorts of things so that you can learn how to use every possible tool nutrition and diet along with tools like rife machine at PMF.
That you're going to gain the best possible health. Now, you watch this little webinar. I want to give you a benefit from this. Anybody watching this webinar can call my office and make a personal appointment with me. We call it a case review that case review.
You'll see the fee and the link at the bottom of this video. Call the office, make that personal appointment with me to half hour visit where we just talk about your case. See if the rife machine is the best tool for you.
I don't think it's the best for everybody. So I don't steer everybody from to that. But it's a great tool to have most of my grown kids have a rife machine at home that they use for my grandkids.
Because hey, kids get sick. You want to write run programs for them that will help them heal. That's completely not invasive. It's not going to affect their body in a negative way. It's to be better than using drugs. At least it's a better first go to this is by new pharmaceutical cabinet.
Now, again, I've been using the rife since the late 90s and using it in my home, the one I have at home, I have one just like this and I have one that's about 12 years old at this time and it still runs perfectly. So it's a great tool call my office schedule and a point with me.
I will be completely honest with you. If I think the rife is a good addition to your home therapy or maybe you should look at something else.
I just think we live at a time of age where we need to be best taking care of ourselves at home and we really have tools in our home where we can heal our families and we can just move to that next level of health without being so dependent upon, you know,
writing to the physician or running to the hospital. It's just the time that we live in. So I want you to have a blessed day. I hope this is a blessing to you. Call my clinic schedule and a point with me. Understand. I'll be praying for you. Bye.